wird gerne über ein Thema einsm ein
Projekt rausnehmen Herr Kuhle klimageld
mhm ist eigentlich eine gute Sache äh
zum zum 1 Januar ist ja der CO2 Preis
gestiegen von 30 auf 45 € soll 25 dann
also nächstes Jahr
weiter auf 55 € steigen also es wird
dann irgendwann wirklich relevant wird
man an der Tankstelle merken wird man
merken wenn man mit Gas oder mit Öl
heizt und so weiter äh und man sagt okay
da brauchen wir eine Kompensation Z
warar die Idee ein kopfbetrag von von
139 € das das was Sozialverbände
vorschlagen pro Kopf äh und dann
passiert folgendes und das ist
interessant in der Chronologie das mal
zu sehen Christian Lindner sagt am 14
Januar das klimageld kommt nicht mehr in
dieser
Legislaturperiode am 17 Januar dre Tage
später macht ihre Fraktion FDP Fraktion
den Vorschlag wie es doch gehen könnte
Ken wir vielleicht doch hin das
irgendwie auszuzahlen organisatorische
Gründe und dann am 22 20 Januar ist
Christian Lindner auch plötzlich offen
für klimageldauszahlungen
2024 wie wie kommt so ein hin und
herzustande also beim klimageld will ich
einmal sagen dass ich davon überzeugt
bin dass wir das brauchen eher schneller
als als später weil wir Preissignale
aussenden über den CO2 Preis die ja dazu
führen sollen dass die Leute
klimabewusster leben aber wenn sich dann
bestimmte Leute ihr Leben nicht mehr
leisten können dann werden Sie erleben
dass sich Leute vom abwenden und kein
Bock auf das Thema haben deswegen muss
das klimageld eingeführt werden und ich
muss sagen dass mir also dass diese
Chronologie in der
Form jetzt gar nicht präsent hatte also
ich habe mit mit Christian Lindner
schlimm oder ja ich
also wenn Sie erlauben würde ich gerne
ein bisschen ausholen weil sie sprechen
jetzt über das klimageld sie haben schon
das Thema Solar angesprochen darüber
werden wir ja gleich noch sprechena
bohengeld gesprochen und ü
heizungsgesetzl be mir ja also est es
geht nicht sozusagen um das große Ganze
und nicht um die Frage ob es geht nur um
die Frage und es ist glaube ich auch
genau dass wie wie das handwerklich
umgesetzt wird und in der politischen
Kommunikation wie das von Menschen
ankommt das verwirrt sie radikal offen
sein versuchen radikal offen zu sein
Herr Erfurt hat gerade richtigerweise
über solarema gesprochen das machen wir
auch gleich noch Neubauer hat das Thema
Wohngeld angesprochen Frau Dunz hat das
Thema heizungsgesetz angesprochen sie
haben jetzt das Thema klimageld
angesprochen das sind vier so
sauschwierige Themen die für viele
Menschen in Deutschland massive
Überforderung bedeuten massive
Überforderung die Leute wissen gar nicht
wo ihm der Kopf steht und ganz ehrlich
das weiß die Politik teilweise auch
nicht will ich einfach einmal offen heiß
das wä es in dem Fall die Politik wir
als Koalition die Bundesregierung die
Beamten die für uns arbeitente wenn ich
das wenn Sie die zu Ende F sie wissen
nicht weiter Sie sie über kin ich will
damit nur sagen dass wir uns in einer so
schwierigen Lage befinden dass mitunter
die handwerkliche Ausgestaltung all
dieser Themen über die wir hier
gesprochen haben unter die Redder kommt
und das merken die Kommunen das merken
die Unternehmen das merkt die
Öffentlichkeit und das ist nicht in
Ordnung und ich will einfach einmal
bekennen dass mir als handelnden
Politiker das sehr wohl bewusst ist und
sehr wohl klar ist ich will aber
trotzdem einmal vorweg sagen dass ich
mich nicht dafür entschuldigen werde als
Teil dieser Regierungskoalition dass die
Ampel das erste Jahr ihrer Existenz im
Grunde nichts anderes gemacht hat als
dafür zu kämpfen dass wir einigermaßen
warm durch den Winter kommenit das erste
Jahr ist im Grunde nur dafür drauf
gegangen und ich ich ma das jetzt mal
Frau Dunst da hat auch sozusagen da ist
auch ein bisschen gestritten worden im
Hintergrund aber ich bin Herrn habbeck
dankbar ich bin Herrn Scholz dankbar und
ich bin Herrn Lindner dankbar dass wir
warm durch dieses erste Jahr gekommen
sind und es muss man auch einmal sagen
auch für die Unternehmen im Land auch
für die Kommunen dass wir dankbar sein
können in einem Land zu leben dass das
hingekriegt hat das hat aber Geld
gekostet das hat der Kanzler hat das mal
ausgerechnet 800 Milliarden gekostet
strompreisbremse gaspreisbremse das was
wir vorher für Corona ausgegeben haben
und jetzt merkt die Mitte der
Gesellschaft so langsam dass das
irgendjemand bezahlen muss aber das ist
nicht das Thema worüber wir hier reden
weil das Geld dann möglicherweise nicht
mehr zur Verfügung steht um das klimgeld
zu machen weil das Geld dann
möglicherweise nicht mehr zur Verfügung
steh um eine verwaltungsdigital ganz
grundsätzlich mir geht nur mir geht nur
was organisatorisches es ist die
Organisation ist schlecht die
Kommunikation ist schlecht und das liegt
daran dass wir eine massive
Überforderung haben der Gesellschaft und
des politischen Systems mit der Masse an
Krisen so macht die Ampel da alles
richtig nein da werden viele Fehler
gemacht da wird mit unter schlecht
kommuniziert aber ich bitte ein bisschen
darum dass wir unsere Erwartungen an
Politik auch mal wieder an der Realität
ausrichten wir können dankbar sein dass
die Politik es hinbekommen hat dass wir
in dieser Situation wo die das gesamte
deutsche Wirtschaftsmodell durch einen
Angriffskrieg in die Luft geflogen ist
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
einigermaßen klar gekommen ist und das
will ich einfach nur sagen deswegen
klimageld ich bin dafür aber es ist sau
schwierig dieses Geld zu finden es ist
gekennzeich wo holen Sie das her also es
muss kommen aus den Einnahmen der CO2
Bepreisung weil der Sinn des klimageldes
ist dass wir das Preissignal CO2
einsammeln und dann an die Menschen
zurückgeben und deswegen muss es im
Grunde aus der Bepreisung des FP schlägt
unter anderem vor 5 Milliarden Euro bei
der chipförderung zu kürzen ist das nein
die FP sag das ist eine falsche
Information die FDP wir haben jetzt also
was wenn wir eines nicht brauchen dann
ist es nachdem wir jetzt endlich ein
Haushalt haben und Unternehmen gesagt
haben die sich jetzt zwei Monate lang
die Frage gestellt haben kriegen wir
jetzt jetzt wieder zu sagen ihr kriegt
es nicht das halte ich für falsch halten
Sie es für falsch oder machen Sie es
nicht ich also Sie haben ja jetzt mir
eine frageestellt ich halte das für
falsch ich hab sie gefragt ob sie es
machen ob sie 5 Milliarden Euro bei der
chipförderung kürzen das ist die
entscheidende Frage nein aber ich bin ST
Fraktionsvorsitzender für innen und
Rechtspolitik
was weiß ich was da was da besprochen
wird also ich halt es für falsch und und
sie sagen das kommt auch nicht kann ich
mir nicht
vorstellen Frau Dunz ja also was ist das
ja also es ist sozusagen was ist das für
Art die FTP schlägt das vor nicht ich
nein die FDP sagt die Bezahlung des
klimageld muss aus den Einnahmen der CO2
Bepreisung kommen die Einnahmen für die
CO2 Bepreisung fließen aktuell in den
Klima und
transformationsfond weiß und aus dem
Klima und transformationsfond wird
aktuell auch diese Förderung für die
Chipfabriken bezahlt wenn man das also
möchte so dann baut das Druck aus alles
was die FDP sagt ist man kann jeden Euro
nur einmal ausgeben das ist alles was
wir sagen also das heißt das kann D
darauf hinauslaufen dass 5 Milliarden in
der chipförderung gekürzt werden nein
wir möchten einfach gerne dass unsere
Koalitionspartner dass die deutsche
Öffentlichkeit und dass jeder der
Erwartungen an die Politik hat in einer
Lage in der wir gerade 800 Milliarden
zur Krisenbewältigung ausgegeben haben
sich darüber im Klaren ist dass jeder
Euro nur einmal aus sind
Jus und wenn wir das machen mit der
chipförderung was ich ich sag das noch
mal ich halte das für richtig dann wird
es schwer Geld zu finden für das
klimageld also doch
also sie würden es doch da rausnehmen
aus der CO2 Bepreisung aus der
chipförderung nein weil das das liegt im
Klima und transformationsfond
schon geht n um die Frage wie
verlässlich ist das darüber haben wir
gerade gesprochen da geht auch beum wie
er verlässlich ist das was sozusagen
zugesagt ist oder erlebt man auch da
jetzt wieder den Moment dass man sagt
okay wir haben zwar diese Milliarden
zugesagt für chipförder wir wollen das
alle der grüne Wirtschaftsminister B
vielleicht wollen wir doch nicht sag
noch mal etwas deutlicher ich halte es
für absolutes Gift für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland einem
Unternehmen zu sagen ihr kriegt jetzt
Geld und zwei Wochen später zu sagen ihr
kriegt es nicht mehr das ist absolutes
Gift für den wirtschaftsst S man nicht
ma bei der e-autoförderung genauso
gemacht nein die e-autoförderung ist
ausgelaufen als moment mal die
e-autoförderung ist doch eine
Unterstützung für den Kauf des Einzelnen
Autos und jetzt haben wir erlebt dass
die dass die
[Musik]
Unternehmen in der gleichen Höhe einen
Rabatt eingeräumt haben und die Politik
ist nicht dafür zuständig dass die
Hersteller von E-Autos das Thema schon
die Hersteller von E-Autos zusätzliche
ge machen es entsteht lassen Sie es mich
vorsichtig sagen es entsteht bei
Menschen die ein E-Auto bestellen der
Eindruck ja da gibt's eine Förderung
dass Menschen in Deutschland ihr Auto im
Wesentlichen selber bezahlen müssen ja
genau so ist es ging ja um die
Verlässlichkeit es ging um die
Verlässlichkeit das und zwar am Freitag
glaube ich verkündet wurde am Montag
kann man die nicht mehr bekommen also
die
hab kurz vor Weihnachten paar Taus Euro
weniger und dass dann die dass diese e
autoprämie meiner Ansicht nach ohne
himim immer falsch war weil nämlich
genau das passiert was Sie gesagt haben
dass es oben drauf geschlagen wird ist
ist was ganz anderes dann hätten sie es
nie machen dürfen aber es den Leuten
kurz vor Weihnachten in einer Frist in
der sie nicht reagieren können also die
Autounternehmen oder die Autohäuser oder
die Konzerne dann wirklich sagen müssen
wir übernehmen das weil ihr das Auto
bestellt habt also diese Fristverkürzung
das ist das was nicht einzahlt beim
Vertrauen in die Regierung ich möchte
aber auf den Punkt den Sie gesagt haben
auch auch die Ampel weiß vieles nicht
und auch die Ampel kann vieles nicht es
gibt so einen schönen Vergleich mit
man möchte nicht wirklich zusehen wie
Wurst gemacht wird aber am Ende muss sie
da sein und über Jahre war es so es kann
sich der einzelne Bürger Bürgerin
wirklich nicht den Kopf des
Finanzministers zerbrechen man hat seine
eigenen Sorgen man muss seinen eigenen
Alltag gestalten ich kann mir nicht
Gedanken darüber machen kriegt er den
Haushalt hin oder nicht sondern ich muss
ein Grundvertrauen haben die können das
besser die machen was anderes die werden
das schon irgendwie hinkriegen die
machen das beruflich die machen das
beruflich jetzt wenn sie sagen sie
können es eigentlich auch nicht finde
ich das sehr ehrlich und ich würde für
einen Zeitraum sagen ist die Bevölkerung
sehr bereit zu sagen die Themen sind so
groß die Krisen sind dramatisch sollen
die sich zurückziehen sollen die sich
einigen und dann sollen sie mit einer
Sache kommen das was sie machen oder was
die Ampel macht nicht Sie persönlich und
auch nicht nur
diete
aber ja am Beispiel und da möchte ich
bei Herrn Lindner bleiben 13 Dezember
der große Auftritt der große kurze
Auftritt Scholz Lindner habbeck erklären
wie das haushaltsurteil nun umgesetzt
wird in einer Sprache die keiner
versteht man weiß nicht was ist der
überschreitensbeschluss warum muss so
der
überschreitensbeschluss ein Synonym für
die Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse weil
man aber Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse
bei der FDP nicht mehr sagen möchte weil
da viele
Assoziation bringt man so ein Wort mit
dem die Menschen erstmal nichts anfangen
können und es wird nichts erklärt und es
wird nur mitgeteilt bleibe ich bei den
Bauern inschnitte bei den Bauern
Doppelschlag
KFZ Steuer Subvention fällt weg und
agrardieselvention fällt weg zwei Tage
später sagt her Lindner der es am 13
Dezember mitunterschrieben hat also bei
den Bauern da können wir e noch mal
nachdenken ganz schön hart da müssen wir
noch mal über nachdem kurz zuvor der
eigene bundeslandwirtschaftsminister
sagt Freunde davon wusste ich nichts hab
nichts mit der Sache zu tun das wird ein
bisschen unterschiedlich beschrieben bei
den Grünen heißt es der sei schon
informiert gewesen aber dass er frauunz
was wissen sie darüber das wird mich
interessieren wird mich auch
interessieren war zumindest nein es war
zumindest so gesagt also es war ja am
Morgen am 13 dezember bekannt geworden
Herr
östdemer hat sehr schnell reagiert
natürlich fragen wir dann auch an bei
den Grünen wieso wusste der das nicht
und da wurde so ein bisschen offen
gelassen dass er jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig überrascht sein kann aber er
musste natürlich reagieren weil er von
Anfang an oder weil er sehr früh gesagt
hat er ist dagegen er war nicht dafür
und dann kann man sich auch davon
distanzieren das Schwierige ist einfach
so wie sie es beschrieben haben ich find
es wahnsinnig sympathisch aber es macht
mir ein bisschen Angst dass das nämlich
genauso ist wie man das denkt die können
es jetzt auch nicht sehr viel besser als
man das so im kleinen Kämmerlein für
möglich hält aber das ist tatsächlich
ihre Position sie müssen den Menschen
das Vertrauen geben ihr müsst euch nicht
drum kümmern wir regeln das für euch und
das wird schwierig mit dem wir
beschließen was wir teilen das mit und
zwei Tage später schmeißen wir alles
wieder um und so ist es mit dem
klimageld auch so der Finanzminister
sagt es kommt nicht dann ist kurz
aufatorisch ja organisatorisch und er
hat ja noch gar nicht mal den
Koalitionsvertrag gebrochen weil da ja
nur steht wir regeln das aber da steht
noch gar nicht eine Zahl und auch es
wird offen gelassen wann aber es kommt
erstmal wahnsinnig Unruh rein und dann
ist bei der FDP
wieder doch nicht anders machen und dann
geht wieder diese Rolle rückwärts und
das ist glaube ich wo die Menschen der
Punkt wo die Menschen einfach nicht mehr
mitkommen Herr Neubauer würde ich gerne
Fragen an dem Punkt
Verlässlichkeit Klarheit und Wahrheit
ist das Thema ja ich finde wir könnten
auch mal ins Auge fassen die Menschen
diesem Land als das zu behandeln was sie
sind nämlich erwachsene Menschen und
dazu gehört eine klare Kommunikation und
ich wünschte mir gerade in dieser
krisenüberlagernden Zeit warum sind wir
nicht ehrlich und sagen den Leuten es
geht nicht alles es geht erstens
zweitens drittens das machen wir weil
und das machen wir in dieser Reihenfolge
und hab bitte keine Sorge der Weg bis
dahin ist nicht asphaltiert aber wir
sind ein kluges Land wir sind immer
damit klar gekommen dass wir irgendwie
auf dem Weg Lösungen erbracht haben wir
haben eine unglaubliche
Wissenschaftslandschaft wir haben eine
starke Wirtschaft ich mir ist auch nicht
bange aber und den Leuten im übrigen
auch nicht was die wahnsinnig macht ist
dass niemand sagt wo es hingeht ich
treff jeden Tag Leute sagen ich langsam
ich ich will irgendwas machen aber ich
weiß nicht was so und wir wir brauchen
Idee für dieses Land wir kommen auser
wir kommen aus einer Pandemie wir haben
ich glaube das ist in Berlin weiß nicht
warum weil dieser Bundestag setzt sich
aus Menschen zusammen die auch zu Hause
wohnen also die müssten das eigentlich
ja auch selber wissen diese Gesellschaft
ist ja nicht gespalten die ist zerteilt
in tausend
wissenswahrheitsinseln das ist ein
Archipel da sitzen fünf Leute die haben
recht da sitzen sechs Leute die haben
recht dazwischen ist ein Wassergraben
und zwischen den vielleicht ein halber
Satz der divergiert wie wollen wir denn
das Zusammenfügen wie wollen wir denn
die alle wieder zusammenbringen wenn
nicht über eine gemeinsame Ideeen Punkt
am Horizont we sag da wollen wir jetzt
hin ich habe momentan ganz ehrlich das
Problem geht mir auch in Sachsen so aber
in Sachsen ist das Prob schon eine ganze
Weile so was sind wir eigentlich was
wollen wir eigentlich sein also wo soll
es denn hingehen ich es geht im mal vor
zurück zuag wir wollen eine Energiewende
Stützen aber wesentliche Teile nicht ich
komme da nicht mehr mit und am Ende des
Tages ich sag mer so im Scherz ich bin
die letzte Meile also ne ich bin die
letzte Meile der Politik zusammen mit
unseren Bürgermeistern wir kriegen das
alles vor die Füße und bei uns stehen
die Leute auf der Matte und und fragen
was ist denn da los so und es wird
zunehmend schwerer also inzwischen muss
man sagen wenn du eine Stunde Zeit hast
versuch ich so zu erklären das kann doch
nicht das Ziel sein und ich sag's noch
mal ein Bürger in diesem Land muss
darauf vertrauen dürfen dass Menschen
die beruflich Politik machen und die
auch im übrigen die letzten Jahrzehnte
immer das Signal ausges gesendet haben
bleiben Sie ruhig wir holen Hilfe wir
regeln alles für
euch jetzt den Job auch machen oder aber
so ehrlich sind und sagen das war nicht
das Konzept wir brauchen euch jetzt auch
das wäre eine Botschaft aber die
vernehme ich so auch nicht ich finde
dass sie was total richtiges gesagt
haben was mir auch auffällt dass die
Gesellschaft so fragmentiert ist dass
die Leute mit unter auch einander gar
nicht mehr aushalten also da sind so
viele sie haben glaub ich Wissens und
wahrheitsinseln genannt dass die
Realitäten auseinandergehen nur in einer
solchen Gesellschaft eine n mal oder ein
Ziel zu organisieren wo alle sich hinter
versammeln und sagen jaw da wollen wir
hin ist wahnsinnig
schwierig aber nicht alle nehmen Sie mal
mein Amt wir haben wir haben ungefähr
1500 Mitarbeitende da haben sie 30% die
freuen sich wenn sich Dinge wenn sich
Dinge nach vorne entwickeln wir
digitalisieren gerade das ist auch
Schmerz aber da gibt's eben 30% die
sagen endlich dann haben sie 30% die
sagen was immer ihr macht wir machen mit
dann haben sie schon 60% mit den sie
arbeiten können so so und und um den
Rest können wir uns dann kümmern also
das ist muss auch mal ein bisschen mutig
sein und wir haben wir haben jetzt wir
haben jetzt gerade wirklich eine
Situation jetzt braucht dieses Land Mut
und nicht ich will nicht jeden Tag hören
ich will nicht jeden Tag hören die
Energiewende ist gescheitert wir werden
morgen alle sterben ich möchte hören wie
es geht und momentan lese ich und höre
ich auf allen Kanälen ganz viele kluge
Leute die mir erklären was alles nicht
geht das weiß ich ich hätte gerne meine
Antwort wie es gehen könnte so und da
wäre es auch vielleicht mal gar nicht so
schlecht auch mehr die kommunale Ebene
in diese ganzen Prozesse mit einzubinden
weil ich glaube ganz fest die Zukunft
dieser Gesellschaft der Demokratie wird
auf der kommunalen Ebene entschieden das
glaube ich
auch weil sie gerade sagten das
fragmentiert das fällt alles auseinander
würden Sie sagen gerade dann ist es
besonders wichtig sehr klar und auch
konsistent zu
kommunizieren ich würde sagen das hilft
ja hilft ja okay ich habe ein Beispiel
für Sie zwei kleine Beispiele sogar W
einmal kurz Rean geht um Landwirte geht
um die Bauern und es geht um ihren
parteichf es geht um den
Bundesfinanzminister um Christian
Lindner der sich im ersten Teil
folgendermaßen äußert gerade eine
europäisch und national so hoch
subventionierte
Branche wird sich nicht jedes
konsolidierungsbeitrags erwähren können
man kann nicht auf der einen
Seite von jetzt der gesenkten
Stromsteuer profitieren wollen man kann
nicht zusätzliche Fördermittel für den
stallumbau fordern und auf der anderen
Seite auch an alten Subventionen
festhalten wer neue Subventionen will
muss auch auf alte
verzichten ich kann Ihnen heute nicht
mehr staatliche Hilfe Versprechen aus
dem
Bundeshaushalt aber wir können gemeinsam
dafür streiten dass sie wieder mehr
Freiheit und wieder mehr Vertrauen für
ihre Arbeit
erhalten
mhm dann be es mal das gleiche gesagt
also ich habe jetzt mir es ernsthaft in
Ruhe
angeguckt und meiner Meinung nach ist
das geht das in die gleiche Richtung
also beim ersten mal hat er gesagt be
ersten Mal hat er gesagt Liebe Bauern
stellt euch nicht so an also empathios
also ihr hab diese ganzen Subventionen
und jetzt nehmen wir euch eine weg und
ihr kriegt eine andere dafür dazu stellt
euch nicht so an das ist das was bei mir
angekommen ist nächsten sagt ich kämpfe
für euch ich ich willür do gerne noch
mehr geben das geht wahrscheinlich nicht
ich kann auch nicht mehr versprechen
aber von Kürzung habe ich da kein Wort
mehr
gehört er hat aber nicht gesagt ich kann
euch keine zusätzliche Hilfe keine
zusätzliche davon war nie die Rede er
hat wie gesagt ich bin nicht
der auch nicht derens also ich kann nur
sagen ich war bei dem ersten bei dem
zweiten war ich nicht dabei bei dem
ersten saß ich vorne in der bei
Dreikönig und ich habe
irgendwie gedacht mensch das ist eine
klare Aussage also ich fühlte mich
irgendwie
angesprochen ich habe aber gespürt weil
ich die Situation der Landwirtschaft
kenne aus meiner niedersächsischen
Heimat und die sind sehr deutlich auch
mit den abgeordn mgen do Bau das auch
gut ja weil die am 223 am Ende das
gleiche gesagt haben wie 224 das geht
so und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht Aue
ob sich das ob sich das in der Form wohl
durchhalten lässt sehr gut und siee da
sehr gut dann ist es zu einem Kompromiss
in der Ampel gekommen
der jetzt übrigens durchgehalten wird ja
also das wird diese Woche
abgestimmt der agrard Diesel der
schrittweise Abbau und die Rückkehr beim
grünen Kennzeichen bei der kfzsteuer das
bleibt und damit sind die Landwirte
übrigens nicht zufrieden auch nicht in
ni Sachsen damit kann ich das kann ich
übrigens sehr gut verstehen warum die
kartofel K nein aber ich will nur einmal
erzählen was ich gemacht habe war dann
bei beim Landvolk bei mir im Wahlkreis
und habe denen gesagt ich verstehe das
ich werde aber für diesen Kompromiss
Stimmen ich werde dafür stimmen ja ich
weil ich ja da haben die gesagt das
finden wir blöd aber wir wissen
zumindest zu schätzen dass du uns sagst
was du tust und dass du hier reinkommst
und dahinterher das gleiche sagst was du
vorher gesagt hast ich hab noch ein
zweites noch ein zweit die Diskussion
über die Landwirtschaft ist übrigens
nicht zu Ende die geht jetzt gerade erst
los haben alle gemerkt
geh das was Lindner da da gesagt hat im
Punkto Bürokratieabbau Entlastung bei
der Einkommensteuer da erwartet die
Landwirtschaft jetzt richtig was und das
muss auch
kommenlingt an chran Lindner gerade was
sie da sag das weiß er das wei er sehr
genau und insofern ist die Diskussion
nicht vorbei aber ich habe persönlich
wei immer bewerten was Christian Lindner
sagt ich kann nur sagen ich hatte ein
Treffen mit landwrten F das irgendwie
gut wenn man bei seiner Position bleibt
das F ich irendwie fand ich irgendwie
auch g deswegen sollten wir uns das noch
mal angucken um vielleicht hinterher
noch mal darüber zu reden wie es ist
wenn man eher nicht bei seiner Position
bleibt bitteschön kommt jetzt die
gefährliche Situation in die mein
Kollege Robert habbeck gekommen ist war
völlig
inakzeptabel die Sachbeschädigungen auch
die angekündigten Blockaden sind
unverhältnismäßig
Landfriedensbruch Nötigung
Sachbeschädigung das sind Fälle für den
Staatsanwalt lassen Sie sich nicht
unterwandern und
instrumentalisieren sie haben sich
verrant bitte kehren sie um die
klimakleber haben das Brandenburger Tor
beschmiert die Bauern haben das
Brandenburger
torehrt und das ist ein
Unterschied und deshalb erwarte ich von
der Politik und von den Medien von allen
die Befürchtungen geäßert haben dass sie
künftig
stattdessen vor der
linksextremistischen Unterwanderung der
klimakleber warnen und deren
Sachbeschädigungen und bkorden
verurteilen denn das ist
gerechtfertigt mus sie selber lachen
gerade
ne also ich habe bei dem Satz in der
Stuttgarter Oper das ist ja dieses
Dreikönigstreffen was immer was da
irgendwie immer stattf genau berümte und
ähm bei dem Satz sie haben sich verrannt
bitte kehren sie um habe ich mir in dem
Moment gedacht hoffentlich kriegen die
das nicht in den falschen Hals und
genauso ist es gekommen weil sich
nämlich die gesamte Landwirtschaft
sozusagen angesprochen hat und ich
glaube das hat Christian Lindner dann
gemerkt und hat sich gedacht das kriege
ich nur gedreht wenn ich selber zu
dieser Demonstration gehe und das fand
ich also das kriege ich aber nicht
gedreht wenn ich dann auf einen völlig
anderen Schauplatz Verweise und dann
plötzlich die klimakleber äh zum äh als
ich versuche mich so ein bisschen
einzuschleimen
äh dass ich die ja dass ich die so
schlecht beurteile und dann mit dieser
Sache komme sie haben das Brandenburger
Tor geehrt weil man mit tausenden von
Treckern davor steht und
die klimakleber im übrigen ja zum Teil
aus dem aus der Politik als Kriminelle
bezeichnet wurden Bauern
aber auch Autobahnen blockiert haben
oder Auffahrten blockiert haben und das
hat hat man dann ja eher als ja robust
oder oder jedenfalls abgemildert kernig
genannt ich weiß nicht ob sie es gehört
haben ich fand man man konnte es hier
über die kurze Einspielung mitkriegen
dass dort gerufen wurde hau ab hau ab
und da sehen sie einfach das zieht nicht
wenn er das gesagt hätte was er in der
Stuttgarter Opa gesagt hat passen Sie
auf hier wird in Teilen eine Grenze
überschritten dass ein
Wirtschaftsminister eine Fähre nicht
verlassen kann obwohl er ein
Gesprächsangebot gemacht hat und das
sehr bedrohlich da aussieht wäre
zumindest eine ehrliche eine aufrichtige
Ansage gewesen und vielleicht hätten
auch einige gedachten das geht wirklich
zu weit dadurch dass er auf die seiner
nach seiner Beschreibung linksradikalen
oder linksextrem klimakleber verwiesen
hat damit hatten die gar nichts zu tun
die sagen was redet der da das geht ja
gar nicht um uns und sie haben sich
wirklich nicht blenden lassen durch die
Ehrung des Brandenburger Tores Herr
Neubauer einmal Herr
Neubauer na ja was ich nicht verstehe in
der Landwirtschaft gibt's Betriebsgrößen
ich habe mir das ein bisschen erklären
lassen bin ja kein
Landwirt aber ich kenne Landwirte ich
habe auch ein Freundeskreis Landwirte
und ich habe mir erklären lassen es gibt
eine
Wirtschaftlichkeitsgrenze also man hätte
vielleicht auch sagen können es gibt
eine Summe X an Agrardiesel pro Betrieb
und jah von keine Ahnung 20.000 lit die
werden entsprechend unterstützt alles
darüber nicht
ich kann das inhaltlich nicht
verurteilen es gibt Menschen die sagen
das wäre ein guter Weg gewesen dann
hätte man die Kleinbetriebe die wirklich
betroffen sind die wirklich die
Unterstützung brauchen und das ist eine
Wahrheit die Kleinbetriebe brauchen
Unterstützung den hätte man es den
Bauern gibt's ja nicht und und den hätte
man damit helfen können und an alles was
größer ist und da kenne ich auch eine
die wirklich hinter vor ganz ehrlich
gesagt haben ob wir das haben oder nicht
spielt spielt für uns keine Rolle und
und das verstehe ich an dem ganzen Spiel
nicht dass man es nicht schafft dann
eine differenzierte Lösung diese
Proteste hätte es gar nicht geben müssen
ich glaub die hätte es nicht geben
müssen herfed Münkler
hier den man kennt und der sagte man
muss einen Kern haben den modifiziert
man dann bei solchen Auftritten so ein
bisschen je nach Auditorium aber hier
sagt er ist der Kern nicht mehr
erkennbar sondern es löst sich einfach
auf in ich rede den die vor mir stehen
einfach komplett nach dem
Mund es ist hart hartes wenn sie nein
ich also ich versuche so ein bisschen
wirklich darüber
nachzudenken was wir veranforderungen an
Politiker stellen und ich find's erstmal
ne ist doch ich find's gut was ist das
Problem ich find g das Problem ist
wissen sie wissen Sie was das Problem
ist da muss ich also da werde ich jetzt
emotional weil ich bin auch Augen und
Ohrenzeuge verschiedener reden und ich
nehme wahr dass Politik zunehmend ihre
Reden abstimmt auf das Auditorium und
das macht es beliebig wenn ich heute und
morgen und übermorgen immer was anderes
erzählen kann weil es mir gerade passt
und weil ich dann vor Ort die Punkte
mache dann ist das nicht das was ich von
Politik erwarte gute Politik beginnt im
übrigen glaube ich dort wo mein Leuten
und das fand ich sehr ehrenwert was Sie
gesagt haben sie dahingehen und sagen
ich habe das so ich werde das mragen
weil ich bin überzeugt davon dass das so
richtig ist so das macht aber kaum noch
jemand ich erlebe manchmal innerhalb von
einer Woche ohne jetzt Namen nennen
wollen denselben Redner oder dieselben
Rednerin vorwechseln im Publikum und
denke
manchmal ich habe irgendwie eine
Halluzination oder stimmt irgendwas mit
mir nicht weil wechseln unter Umständen
Position in von 48 Stunden so schnell
kommt man gar nicht mit aber die Leute
kommen damit und die Leute nehmen das
weil sie hören zu und das ist ja das das
ist das was meine Botschaft ist noch
hören sie zu und noch hätten wir die
Möglichkeit vielleicht mit dem klaren
Konzept Menschen noch davon zu
überzeugen dass es ganz gut wäre mit
diesem politischen System irgendwie
gemeinsam Zukunft zu machen aber das
dieses Zeitfenster was wir noch haben um
das zu versöhnen um da wieder
Glaubwürdigkeit und Vertrauen
herzustellen wird immer kleiner ich
glaube wir haben da eine ziemlich
ähnliche Sichtweise drauf weil ich das
ja gerade mit dem Treffen mit den landwi
beschrieben habe ich habe als ich das
gemacht habe und zu den Landwirten
gesagt habe passt auf es hat sich jetzt
was dran noch geändert aber es ist nicht
100% das was ihr wollt und es wird auch
nicht in diesem Haushalt kommen eine
innere Freiheit verspürt weil sie
nämlich nicht befürchten müssen dass
hinterher irgendeiner kommt und sagt
moment mal du hast aber gestern genau
das Gegenteil gesagt also wenn sie
konsistent ungefähr das gleiche sagen im
Kern ja dann macht ein das innerlich
auch ein bisschen frei und warum macht
ihr parteichf das nicht so und jetzt
finde ich Christian Lindner hat ich find
das interessant das ist so ein
interessanter Modus Lindner Bilder zu
analysieren jetzt hat Christian Lindner
als ersten Satz warum das warum finden
Sie das so ja weil ich das weil ich das
irgendwie so ein bisschen wohlfeil finde
hier im im Warmen kämerlein zu sitzen
und einen Bundesfinanzminister der
dahingeht als einziges Kabinettsmitglied
und da geredet hat zu zensieren das
finde ich
irgendwie man kann das alles kritisieren
und so aber es ist ein bisschen
sozusagen
es ist es ist auch nicht
leichtation
das ist nein überhaupt nicht aber das
ist doch Volk der Mann macht das
beruflich das ist ein Profi der sitzt
seit Jahren sitzt er dort wo er sitzt
und steht dort weß doch ganz genauumn e
nicht mehr staatliche Unterstützung
versprechen ihr seid die guten hat also
gesagt dass es bei dem Kompromiss bleibt
so kann man das auch anders sagen ja
meinet wegen so ich kann nur sagen ich
warum diese warum dieser Ausweg über die
klim und das ist doch das ist doch
wirklich Entschuldigung man mag davon
halten was man möchte ich habe dann eine
klare Sicht drauf und sage ich bin froh
dass es eine junge Generation gibt die
sich die bereit ist für grundsätzlich
Dinge einzutreten ob die weiter Mitte
richtig sind ist eine andere Geschichte
aber in dem Moment drängt sich es auf
dass man etwas gesagt hat was vermutlich
diese Zielgruppe die da stand trägt und
das finde ich sollten wir uns künftig
verbieten schlicht ergreifend dieses
gegeneinander spielen wir haben das
machen wir auch bei Migration ne warum
funktioniert Migration nicht weil wir
den einen sagen dass dass es ihnen nicht
gut geht weil es die gibt wir machen das
immer und das das geht nicht auf es geht
einfach nicht auf wir müssen anfangen
mal unsere Hausaufgaben zu machen und zu
arbeiten und weil alles andere stärkt
alles andere stärkt nur negative Tendenz
in diesem Land und an den arbeiten wir
uns dann oben drein auch noch Abstatt
endlich mal einfach zu sagen wir gucken
nicht in Rückspiegel wir gucken auch
nicht wer davon profitiert wir machen
jetzt einfach mal vernünftigen Weg und
dem werden sich die Leute
anschließeniten verstehe warum die Rede
nicht gefällt aber ich habe Respekt
dafür dass der
bundesfinanz GI ke Z W man das einpreist
und sagt das war eine harte Situation
ist
aberotdem ich will auch nicht der
sozusagen der der der Therapeut der
Politiker hier sein ja und so bisschen
den Eindruck erwck hten alle ganz
schweren ganz schweren Job und bräuchten
irgendwie Mitleid oder Lob oder so das
ist nicht die Kategorie aber mir gefällt
nicht dass mit dieser Formulierung die
machen das
beruflich so getan wird als hätten wir
irgendwie die Politiker und das Volk und
das sei ja ja genau ja das ist ja gut
dann ist ja gut aber das seien sozusagen
zwei unterschiedliche Typen Mensch äh
und die haben im Grunde nichts mehr
miteinander zu tun die ein M die meinen
ja aber wir sind für vier Jahre gewählt
wir wir sind auch Bürgerinnen und Bürger
wir stehen zur Wahl wir diskutieren
miteinander lassen sie uns ich finde sie
haben sehr kluge Sachen gesagt her
Neubauer aber lassen Sie uns B nicht den
Eindruck erwecken dass wir eine
abgeschottete politikertruppe
hab die machen das beruflich ja die
müssen das Lösen bitte bekannt geben was
die Lösung ist und wir konsumieren dann
als Volk die Politik das darf auch nicht
passieren und deswegen bin ich froh dass
es unterschiedliche Ministerinnen und
Minister gibt die mit unterschiedlichem
Sound auch zu bauerndemos gehen und ich
hoffe dass das auch weiter
unterschiedliches nicht mal das ist das
Problem der unterschiedliche Sound ist
nicht das Thema es es ist um die Frage
ob du dich die Frage ob du dich in
deiner Botschaft in deiner Kernbotschaft
um 180° drehst oder nicht ne war nicht
180 aber sag mal ganz weit weg davon
waren wir nicht und ich glaube wir haben
aber rausgearbeitet und ich finde sie
haben Recht WN sie sagen man sollte
einen einen Kern haben zu dem man steht
und ich kann sagen als Politiker das
macht innerlich frei